are you really liking this Gambit don't
you
well let's move on as in today's episode
we are going to look the second choice
by the white Camp namely Knight to C3
and I must admit that whenever my
opponent plays this move I feel like I'm
winning the game on the spot
well that much confident I'm having in
this line and I hope that after watching
this video you will gain it too
thank you
now here if you check the database by
far the most popular choice is D4
but I don't like that move because the
position remain block so in the true
Spirit of the elephant Gambit I am going
to recommend you capture on e4 and after
Knight takes E4
here what I like about this line you
grab the center with F5
so white has basically three choices
and the first move which is in fact a
tricky one white can play Knight
captures E5
and the point is if you foolishly take
this Knight then Queen to H5 is a deadly
reply
so all we need to do is just calm our
nose down and look out for the better
option to award This Disaster
and accordingly I think the best move
fit in is Queen to D4 attacking two spot
so white response is fools he has to
give this check and after G6
what else Knight captures G6
okay
first we are going to capture this
Knight on e4 with a check
and after Bishop to E2 I recommend this
nice idea first you hit the queen
and after Queen to H3
you just give white the whole Rook by
playing Knight to C6
many of you will say hang on but isn't
that you giving up the Rook for the two
pieces
indeed that is going to happen but the
big point is after Knight to D4 in fact
black has two threads and white cannot
Parry both of them
there is a mate as well as four corn C2
coming up
and after the best response Queen to D3
we have this nice sequence Knight
capture C2 check King to Devon
Queen catches D3 Bishop captures D3 and
at the end when we gobble up the rook in
the corner we have a very funny position
on the board where both the knights are
sitting in the corner and most likely
they are going to disappear from the
board very soon but if you count the
material after that black is emerge with
a clear piece up
so I think this model line completely
refute Knight captures E5
the second bad move I can play over here
is Believe It or Not Knight to G3 which
doesn't look like that much problematic
but against all of this line what black
wants to do is he wants to always push
on with E4 and if Knight retrew back
then after Knight to F6 black already
get an advantage as well as space
so nope the only way to keep fight in
the game is Knight to E5 which has again
the same idea Queen to H5 check
well you might think we need to stop it
right
nope guess what we are going to allow it
by playing Bishop to E6
white has two major choices
and amongst them if we continue with D4
then my recommendation is you play
Knight to D7 attacking on E5 and after
Knight takes and queen takes
with the space and the leading
development where black is aiming to
Castle long
in this line black is always slightly
better
so nope D4 is not the right option
if white has come this far then he has
to go with Queen to H5 check and after
our G6 and Knight captures G6
I propose this nice exchange sack
starting with Bishop to F7
okay now we have some forcing moves
Queen captures F5 Bishop captures G6
Queen to E5 check
Queen to E7
Queen captures Rook
and at the end when we play Knight to F6
hahaha
you can see I have highlighted by the
arrows what really black wants to do is
he wants to take this Knight on D7 then
he wants to Castle and then move the
bishop somewhere which at the end grab
the whole Queen
let me remind you if that happened white
will lose his queen and the Knight for
two Rooks which is always good for the
black camp
one of my recent game will give you a
great idea what I'm talking about
here my opponent who was 2200 rated
player continue with Bishop to E2
I go for the plan which I have just
mentioned Knight to D7
now we play H4
and after I Castle his intention is to
play H5
okay no worries I simply dropped my
Bishop back to F7
and now indeed there is a threat of
Bishop at six and funny enough white
doesn't have any resources to conquer
that
for example in the game my opponent lash
out with Knight to F5
attacking my queen but after Queen to E5
his own Knight get attacked and when he
saved it with Knight to E3
what else Bishop 26.
well by force white is losing the queen
so my opponent tried the Moon Knight to
G4
but after just one move Queen to G5
white realized that he has a completely
lost position
he took my Rook I recapture and you
should note that D4 doesn't work here
because of Queen to if I check
so my opponent sadly take on H6
but after Queen takes
as I have mentioned earlier if you count
the material
we have Queen and Knight against Turok
and a pawn which is in fact with the
accurate play a completely
winning Advantage for the black camp
so I guess with the small line you can
understand now that Knight to G3 can be
comfortably met with Bishop to E6
okay so let's look at the main move
Knight to C3
and after that yup our move is very
obvious evil
and interestingly enough I found a nasty
trap if your opponent continue with
Knight to G1 which is in fact more
common at the lower level
let me show you how crafty this trick is
after Knight to G1 I propose you
continue with
night to F6
and when white plays Bishop to C4
you just play Knight to C6
so idea is very obvious that if white
take out his Knight on E2 then after
Knight to H5 white will lose the bishop
pair
so accordingly first White has to stop
this by playing either the move A3 or A4
let's say A3
and when we play Bishop to C5
white can take out his Knight
comfortably on the E2 Square
so everything looks good white is ready
to Castle but nope we have the another
deadly trick occurs in this line with
Knight to G4 attacking on F2
so naturally white is going to Castle on
the king side
afterwards
yup if you have watched my Goring Gambit
as well as advanced Stafford Gambit
lessons then you can easily spot Black's
idea
Queen to H4
and I think after this white is in a
completely losing position
there is a double thread so white has to
play as three and after that black
option is very simple you take on F2
if white try to Save the Queen
then he will not forget this pictures
Checkmate in his whole life and I'm sure
some of you already knew about it
Knight captures H3 double discover Jack
King to H1
now the Knight comes backs again with a
double check and after King to G1 and
the move Queen to H1
white King has been murdered on his own
bed
so moving the queen is right out of the
equation
that means the only option left for the
white is to take on F2 but after Bishop
takes F2 and King to H1
once again if you count the material
this time around black is a clear
exchange up
so this is one of the wonderful tricky
line exists if your opponent choose the
move Knight to G1
I think after E4 the most challenging
response is Knight to E5
again going for that Queen H5 business
but this time around black has equally a
tricky reply
Queen to D4
and I can't tell you how many people has
fallen for the queen to H5 check they
think that black has made an error and
now we get the rook in the corner but
guess what we are going to play G6 and
after Knight to G6
white to his horror find out that black
can actually take this Knight as his
Rook is well protected
the maximum white can do over here is
Queen check and after King to d8
yes indeed our King has been misplaced
but the most important factor is via
peace up
so watch out for this great trap which
occurs frequently in the online chess
so in the majority of the cases you are
going to see the Moon Knight to C4
and after this I am going to recommend
you start with Bishop to E6
attacking the Knight
and white has two choices and amongst
them if you think that Knight to E3 is
the right one then you are absolutely
wrong because
no wonder this is a blunder by the white
and let me show you what is the reason
first of all black would love to play F4
here but the problem is white has this
double check which ruin all the fun so
my recommendation is first you play
Knight to C6 and now no matter whatever
white plays we are going to lash out
with F4
for example let's say white doesn't
identify a threat and play a random move
E3
then black can indeed play the move F4
and the big point is Knight to G4
doesn't save anything as black has this
nasty reply H5 and that poor Knight is a
complete corner
so that is the big threat guys and
accordingly if white wants to save the
piece then he has to play D3 in this
position
but even after this white is completely
losing
so before I move on I like you to pause
this video and find out a killer
sequence that will completely destroy
the white camp
are you ready
please pause the video if you need more
time I'm going to show you right now
first black will play F4
Knight to C4 what else
now you play Bishop to B4
threatening on C3
so again white response is false he has
to play Bishop to D2
and after that we have this nice
sequence Bishop takes C4
Pawn takes C4
E3 attacking the bishop
Pawn takes Pawn takes
and if the bishop moves then the C3
Knight drops with a check
so the only logical reply here is
Queen to E2 pinning down the E3 Pawn but
guess what
black wins elegantly from here
starting with
Queen check
Queen takes
Pawn takes on D2 with a check and after
King takes
we have this long castle where at the
end of the whole sequence black clearly
emerged with the whole Bishop advantage
so you can see how crafty these lines
are and even though some of the best
responses by wide completely fails at
many occasions
so it is pretty clear that white cannot
play Knight to E3 and he has to play the
move D3
well against this I am going to
recommend more or less the same
variation starting with Bishop to B4
Bishop to D2
Bishop takes C4 Pawn takes C4 and yes
indeed this time we don't have the movie
3 but after Knight to F6
what black is aiming is he wants to
enter into the end game where White's
double Pawn is a clear-cut target
here white has tried few moves for
example if he play A3 then Bishop to C5
is a strong reply
in the case of Knight to B5
we actually achieve what we want to do
namely exchange everything on D2 and
then play Knight to E6
whereupon this space and White's double
Pawn already gives black a nagging age
so Knight to be far actually allow black
what he wants to do
and apart from it I think against all of
the moves black Plan of campaign more or
less remainsing
now before we finish I like to show you
my high profile game against an I am in
this line where he continued with Bishop
to E2
I simply continue with my peace
development Knight to C6 and after a
White Castle I decided to put my rule on
the D file
okay there is a threat so my opponent
plays Bishop to E3
and naturally enough I unleash my Attack
Of The Rook
by playing Queen to E5
white plays Queen to C1
but unfortunately that allows my knight
intrusion
on D4 Square
so I have a threat of Bishop capture C3
and then Knight captures E2
and indeed that Knight is so strong that
my opponent feels that he has to remove
it immediately
and after my Rook captures
white didn't like the idea of f4 coming
up so he responded with G3
but I think this is a great time
inaccuracy as after the simple
continuation Bishop capture C3 Pawn
capture C3 and the move Rook to D6
white has absolutely disgusting Pawn
structure on the Quinn side
and even though in the time trouble I
blew up the whole game if you put this
position in any chess engine
it will tell you that black is
marginally better
thanks to this weird Pawn structure but
the white Cam
that's it guys so now you are equipped
with the same knowledge I am having in
this line and as I have shown in this
video that after Pawn takes Knight takes
F5
it doesn't matter however white plays
not only black has some nasty tricks and
traps exist in this line but with the
space in the center and the free piece
development this line always serves
better for the black camp
thank you for watching this video feel
free to like subscribe and comment and I
will meet you in my next episode very
soon
bye and take care